- I don't have a lust of money,
and I don't have a, I actually don't
even have a love of money.
I don't buy it to, like, yeah I'm the man,
like nah, I feel like I got a lot left.
Everybody got something
to be thankful for,
even the homeless man.
If he wanted to, he could be like
yo, I'm breathing today, like.
I'm not actually good
at being resourceful.
I'm getting better.
- He's a rapper, record
producer, and songwriter.
He received a nomination
for best new artist
at the 54th Grammy Awards.
He's the first rapper in 25 years
to have a platinum-selling album
without any guest appearances.
He's J. Cole, and here's my take
on his top ten rules for success.
Number one is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick around all the way
to the end for a special bonus clip.
- Do you want to make a lot of money?
- I do want to make a lot of money,
but that's only for safety purposes.
Like, I don't have a lust of money,
and I don't have a, I actually don't
even have a love of money.
Like, you got people,
and I know these people,
you know, they're my friends, and
they're also rappers that I know.
They love money, they're addicted
to getting money, and that's cool too
cause that's what makes some of
the most successful businessmen.
I don't love money like that.
I love the comfort, and the safety,
and the ability to retire my mom,
or like if there's a
problem with my brother,
or if my father has a problem,
I like that feeling of
being able to provide.
So, that's the thing
I do love about money.
But, to tell you the truth, what makes
me the happiest is the
music, working on the music.
I'm in the studio right now with
Elle Varner, and I'm producing
for another person, that makes me happy.
That makes me way more
happy than getting a check.
My album comes out, the response
is amazing, that makes me way more happy.
If I write a song, I made Let Nas Down,
a song off my album,
when I made that song,
the feeling that I had
after I made that song
is way more important
to me than making money.
You know?
But yeah, of course I want to make
a lot of money, so I can be safe,
just in case something pops
off and I might need it.
Like, I don't buy into my own hype.
You know?
Like, I'm grateful for the reactions,
and the appreciation, but I don't
buy into like, yeah I'm the man, like nah.
I feel like I got a lot left, like I
want to be here for years, like.
I don't, being hot in 2013 is cool,
you know, and being critically-acclaimed
in 2013 is cool, but like what
about 2020, like where am I going to be?
I don't want to be making a documentary
20 years from now talking about,
like, this as if it was the end.
I want to still be present, and still
be making music, I want to be like,
you know, Bruce Springsteen or something.
Like, making song that are relevant.
If a tragedy happens, make a song,
and I can just put it out and people,
you know, people know I'm
still speaking for them.
I want to be like that, have
my art always appreciated.
- [Interviewer] What was
going through your mind
when everything was just falling apart,
and you don't even know, like you
don't even know what to do, and basically
everything was just falling apart
and you just trying to find a way.
Like, what was going through your mind?
Did you ever think, like, damn what
if this don't happen for me, you know?
- My mind never worked like that
in the beginning, when like when I
wasn't on, I never had those thoughts.
But, I can relate to that, only
because there came a
point after my first album
was already out, where I started
like really getting down on myself.
Like, man, like I really, like,
I really just dropped the ball, man.
Like, this didn't go
how I wanted it to go.
Like, I didn't come out how I
foresaw myself coming out, and I
was really getting down on myself,
and it felt, it really did feel
way more, and everybody else is looking
at me like, are you crazy, you're the
number one album in the country,
you got a Grammy nominee, and I'm
not seeing or appreciating any of that.
So what I can say is you have to
stop looking at what you don't have,
and what's not happening for you,
and start appreciating, like,
what you do actually have.
Like, my man you got on a nice watch,
like your hat is fresh, like you
in New York City, it's the land
of opportunity, you know what I mean?
You're a good looking guy, I'm sure
you got, maybe, a girlfriend, like
there's a lot of things, your family,
there's a lot of things
to be grateful for,
and that's the only way you can
climb out of, like, a place of focusing
on what you don't have is by focusing
on, like man, what do I
have to be thankful for.
And everybody got something
to be thankful for,
even the homeless man, if he wanted to
he could be like, yo I'm breathing today.
Like, you know what I mean?
Like, my arms work, my legs work.
You can start very small
and it's a process,
but that's how you can get up out
like, of a negative space like that.
Music is my passion, man.
Production.
Besides the actual art of rapping,
there's a lot I want to accomplish on the
production end, and the production side.
I would love to try my hand at acting.
My mother's an actress.
She tells me all the time
that she thinks it's in me.
She's been telling me that for years.
Boy, you an actor, I'm telling you.
She always tells me, you know,
so I would love to try my hand at that
and see if I'm any good.
- Do you use your access, I mean,
you probably could call Will
Smith and get some advice.
- I could.
- Do you do that stuff?
- I have the connection,
at least, to do it.
I don't, I guess cause I'm not passionate
about it yet, it's just a thought.
But hopefully when I become passionate,
or when I take it serious,
I will use that card,
you just gave me the card to use.
You gave me the idea for it, so.
But yeah, I do have access.
I'm not actually good
at being resourceful.
I'm getting better.
That's another thing, to
be a great businessman,
I think you have to be
incredibly resourceful.
I'm new to business, period, I never
was good with money, so
having money is new to me,
and therefore using my resources,
being a great businessman is new to me.
Only reason I was in New York was
cause I wanted to do music, so school
was just, like in my eyes, school
was just like the temporary thing
that I was doing while
I was chasing the dream.
So then, about my sophomore, junior year
is when I was like you know what,
wait, I got to refocus
and re-shift my energy
to the music thing, that's when I
was going on a rampage, I probably
hit up every A and R on Myspace,
but I sent these same people messages,
you know, like through
Myspace or whatever,
or called their office.
I called it up and was like yeah,
you've reached Dale Jones
for Atlantic Records,
please leave a message after the beep.
Yo, I left the longest rap
on his voicemail though.
I just rapped on his voicemail,
and I think I might have left my number
at the end or something like that,
but like, of course I
never got called back,
you know, I wouldn't
even call somebody back
that did that, but it's just to show you
the type of I was doing.
I was trying anything and everything.
So time was running
out, it was coming close
to graduation, and I hadn't really
made any major moves, but I always felt
like it was coming, it was coming.
So man, it took after I graduated,
it still took another year-and-a-half
after I graduated to actually get to J
and then get all that stuff rolling,
but you know, it's all a process man,
you got to believe, have faith.
I always felt like it was
waiting around the corner,
so that's why I just kept going.
- Let's talk about having faith
in that, and belief, how did you
remain, at that point, to have like a
strong faith in what you're doing?
- Man, cause I felt like for years,
this is years of work and years
of me knowing that this is
what I'm supposed to do,
I think when you believe in yourself
then you know, like, you just know.
So even when you're
working a part-time job,
and you getting paid eight dollars
an hour, and you like damn
I don't want to be here,
you know, if you truly know what's coming,
then you don't mind doing that
because you know it's temporary.
This is temporary, and
this is temporary sacrifice
for what I want to end up doing.
So, that's what kept me going.
Cause I never questioned
it, it was always like
well, I'm closer.
Today I'm closer than I was yesterday,
and it's that mentality that's going to
get you through it or not.
That's with anything, that's not
even just music, that's life, period.
- And to expand on that, you believe
that you control your
destiny, where your life goes.
How important is that, please,
I want you to tell the people out there,
inspire them with the story, like
how you came up to
where you are right now.
- Certain things happen in your life
that you have no control over, but life
is about how you react to those things,
and handle those things, and I don't know,
those occurrences or whatever.
So I absolutely believe that you choose,
like, where you want to
go, what you want to be,
and it's up to you to get there.
As a rapper, there's very few greats
that I studied, and I
still continue to study,
and Nas is obviously one
of them, it's obvious.
I really had his lyrics
printed on my wall,
they used to have this site it
was called OHHLA, original
hip-hop lyrics whatever,
archive, yeah somebody know.
And then you print them out.
So, I would print these joints out,
and I would print 'em up,
and hang 'em up on my wall,
and literally if you walk in my room,
you might be like what's
wrong with this kid.
I'm staring at the wall like this,
just reading the lyrics
because I wanted to know
what it was like to be that good.
You know what I mean?
Like, and I was rapping at the time,
so I wanted to know, and it
was my goal to be that good.
I wanted to somehow try
to master the style.
I felt like if I read it enough,
if I listened, I used to go to sleep
listening into I Am, you know what I mean,
people would be sleeping on that album,
I'd be trying to tell them that man's
spitting note for real on that album.
I used to go to sleep
listening to that album
because I wanted to try to
master the style if I could.
You know what I mean, and you can't
master that style, but I felt about you
how you probably felt about Rakim,
or Kane, or G Rap, or whoever it was
that you looked at like the god.
That's how I felt.
Any musician, period, any artist I think
just absolutely do will
sing your heard, period.
Say what's on your mind, speak what's
in your heart and how you really feel.
When you're trying to be something else,
when you're trying to
fit into what's going on,
it's like you kind of stray away
from your path a little bit, and sometimes
you want to expand your
style, and like grow,
and that's always good, but like
never veer too far from who
you are, you know, as a person.
Best way to establish yourself
on the Internet is to start small.
Once again, be humble.
First of all, you got to make sure
your music is correct, there's
a million niggas online doing music,
but once you feel like your music
is truly correct, stay
humble, start small,
go to like some of the smaller blogs
that, you know, they don't get
as many hits, but maybe they'll
post your if they like it.
You know, shout out to DC to BC,
and you know, like Part of Me Duke,
and people like smaller blogs that
I with are Herfection, you know.
Maybe if they feeling your you got a shot,
like if they put it up
there's a way better chance
that the big blogs will pick it up,
especially after seeing it, you know?
If Herfection picks it up, then maybe
DC to BC puts it up, and Part of Me Duke,
that's three more smaller blogs
that still have good followings that are
putting your up so the bigger blogs
like 2DOPEBOYZ might pick it up now,
and then after they bring it up now,
so that's the best way, just start.
And big dreaming it just starts small,
and then, you know, but the Internet
is not the end all, be all, man.
It's a lot more to go.
- Are you going into a club with $80,000
in a garbage bag like some people we know?
- No, I've seen that.
I've seen that live, in person.
I can't do that, I'm too afraid
of losing, of going back over there
to ever blow money
without thinking about it.
There's a song on my album called
Chaining Day, and this is the type
of artist I am, and this
album is like this to a tee.
Most rappers are going to say paid
a hundred thousand dollars for the chain,
and they just, you know,
show you they chain.
That's a good ass song, I paid
a hundred thousand dollars for the chain.
I paid a hundred thousand
dollars for the chain.
dollars for the chain,
and that's their whole
song, and the whole song
they'll tell you how they spend
a hundred thousand dollars for a chain.
My song is going to tell you, like
my thought process before I paid all
of this money for some jewelry,
which is really was like this, like
oh my god, like yo, yes, do I want it?
Yes.
How much?
People pay that?
And then my internal conversation
was just like yo, you know better.
Like, you definitely know you know better
than to spend this type of money.
But, do you want it, is it worth it,
what's the investment?
Well, when I'm on stage, it's
going to look really good, so you could
say it's for your career, oh man.
It does look nice.
How much?
And then it's more internal conversation.
Man, you know what you could do
with all that money, you know whose lives
you could change with that type of money
you going to spend out on chains?
So that other song was I spent
a hundred thousand dollars
on a chain, I spent a hundred, and then
in my song you get all of these
internal thoughts that led me to finally
be like, alright, here you go.
And then I wrote the check.
Or, at least, I gave them my
card, you know what I mean?
But, I gave you my thought process first,
before I just spend a hundred
thousand dollars on a chain.
- J. Cole, value added.
- When we young, and even when we old,
the world is constantly
pumping us with images, right,
about what life should be about.
Constantly telling us what life is about,
what it should be about.
In the States it's called
The American Dream.
I don't know what the
they call it in England,
but I know you all got it, and I know
it includes the same, what
does it always include?
A lot of money, a big ass house,
a brand new car, and a wife that's like
not even genetically
possible to have, right?
That's what they tell
us we need to be happy,
even though the world is set up
so that 99% of us can't never have this.
But we idolize the people that do have it,
we sit and we watch, and we go
oh my god, their life looks so perfect,
look what they doing, oh my god.
And I came here tonight to tell you all,
I was the same person
that was sitting down
watching like, oh my god, they
look so perfect must be nice.
Imma go get it.
And then I went and got
this, but when I got there,
I'm telling you all,
up close and personal,
that don't feel right,
that don't seem right, man.
And I'm coming back to tell you all
all that they told you, full
of, it's not what's important.
It's not what it was.
How do I know that?
I know that because right now, it's a man
he got millions of dollars,
he got a billion dollars,
and he's miserable, right?
But you got a family that come from
where we come from, worse conditions
than where we come from, they couldn't
afford a ticket to this show tonight
if they wanted, but yet somehow
they got more happiness and joy
in they life right now, than this man
will ever have in his.
How is that possible?
How is that even possible?
That everything we thought we needed,
he got it, and he's miserable,
and they have nothing,
and they got happiness?
What do they have that he don't got?
- [Audience] Love.
- What's that?
- There's British people here.
Too smart.
(audience cheers)
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I made this video because
Khari Butler asked me to.
So, if there's a famous entrepreneur
you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of the ten clips
had the biggest impact on you, and why,
what change you're going
to make as a result
of watching this video.
Leave it in the comments, and
I will join in the discussion.
Finally, I wanted to
give a quick shout out
to Patricia Romboletti, thank you so much
for pre-ordering my book,
it means a lot to me.
It means the world to me.
For those of you who want your chance
at a shout out in a future video,
you can check out the information
in the description below.
Thank you guys so much for watching,
continue to believe, or
whatever your one word is.
And I'll see you soon.
- This thing is a long-distance race,
this business is a long-distance thing.
You want to be relevant,
you want to be around,
you want to be providing for your family
10, 15, 20 years from now, you just said
Jay Z's about to be 44.
He put out his first album when he was 25,
that's 20 years of relevancy, you know
and like of just, so
that's what it teaches me.
Being around all of these guys,
even Uncle Wes, it's like been in this
for awhile, you know what I mean?
He's been around the game of basketball
for a long time, it's longevity.
So, when I make decisions, whether
which single, this show or that show,
or this tour, should
I get on this feature,
should I take this money to do this song,
or should I make my
decisions more calculated
about is this something that's going to,
like does this further my career,
or does this, you know?
I think about things in that manner.
What does this do for me in the long run.